child mama day
is back i am in the bb house i am
about to lose my mind i'm so excited
devon
you're back you're about to head in how
are you feeling
so amazing like redemption that's all i
can say
like redemption you know people pray for
an opportunity to play this game once
i've played twice and now i'm back for a
third time so it's like
if history is rewriting if if the
history is writing itself
then i've experienced what it's like to
be in pre-jury
i've experienced what it's like to be a
jury member it's time to win
it's time to win like that's the way to
make the story come full circle it's
time to win
so i'm ready should we just say it right
now
third time's the charm third time is the
charm
and we got it down back i'm ready i'm so
ready okay
so you're ready you want this how badly
do you want to win
i want to win so bad and it's not even
from like uh
i have a point to prove type of stand
it's it's more so
i love this game so much and i've loved
this game since i was a
child you know watching this with my
grandmother and just growing up on it
like i told julie when i was evicted in
season 18
i would play this game again and again
and again and again
i love the game i love it so much so
what's it going to feel like to step
foot into that house to see julie again
you know coming back into the house and
seeing julie is going to be
amazing i know julia gonna be like girl
look and i'll be like i'm bad girl like
this is the time this is
it this is the one so you know if it's i
wouldn't say it's a lot of pressure
going in but there is a fire that is lit
that has never been there before like
it's it's hot
let's scan those flames yes
i mean what is julie gonna say to you if
you don't win on this one like
it's right you know julia's definitely
to drag me if i don't win this time
she'll be like look girl
now hey you know so i know the first
moment i see her she i'm like divine now
this is the third time
shut up go in there don't you say
nothing
i got it julie i got it it's so funny i
know she's mad that's why i purposely
when i sat next to her i flung my hair
shade 101. so how have you been prepping
for this have you been watching seasons
have you been working out have you been
staying inside to make sure you don't
get corona before you got called in
definitely been preparing for this you
know i've been working out
trying to make sure i can build up my
endurance because that was one of my
downfalls you know
and i have to stop blaming my asthma for
everything because
i gotta get it together you know so i've
been doing that i've been studying this
game but i didn't want to study too much
because i feel like that was my downfall
in my first season
i knew too much about the show and i was
expecting things
that were never going to happen you know
i'm like oh i gotta watch out for this i
gotta watch out for that and it's like
devon that's not even a part of this
season you know so i don't want to get
back into that space where i overplay
so this time i'm like you know what go
in there and live in the moment
so a little less strategy this time yeah
more more so goals you know goal number
one go in there shut up
go number two go in there and play beat
by beat by b
and when the twists come be able to
easily adapt how did you feel heading
into this with the pandemic i mean
have you been staying at home because
i'm sure it would have been
heartbreaking to
get diagnosed with corona before you're
about to head in
yeah definitely i've been extra careful
with everything that's going on with the
pandemic you know
i'm already a germaphobe so i'm already
one that likes to wash their hands 35
000 times a day
you know and then i'm also a mother so
it's not just me i have to be careful
for it's also my
child you know so i've been preparing
for that and i've just been like okay
i know i'm clean negative results ain't
no corona got to me miss rona ain't
knocked on my doorstep
let's play give her away keep her out of
the big brother house
you are not welcome here no miss rona
going to find you a seat
away from me what have you been
undergoing in the weeks leading up to
this
i mean are you guys getting tested a ton
of being sequestered before going into
the house
you know leading up to this cbs has
really cracked down on the house guests
you know
i have been tested numerous times my
nose is raw i have been tested
numerous times and then i've also been
in a strict
quarantine you know they're they're very
i can appreciate it they are very
protective of our health and our safety
and i'm so grateful to cvs for that it's
not like
well let's hurry up and throw this
production together and get it out there
it's like no we're going to take the
extra steps
to make sure each of our houses are
taken care of and for that i'm so
grateful
what's going through your mind when
you're getting that that thing shoved up
your nose for the test
you know i'm not a big fan of stuff
going up my nose i don't even like to do
the
whatever that name is i'm ooh i can't
i'm not that person
so when the doctor is like and i'm like
wait a minute and you know he's like
well we gotta go a little further i'm
like well it ain't nothing else to go
like i feel the wall right here what are
you pushing again it's just
oh i don't like it are you just like i
gotta win
for the game third time you know if the
doctor is doing it i'm like they might
stay focused
stay encouraged you know what it's for
you're doing this for cadence get it
done it's okay
so yeah what kind of mental toll does
all this take as well because
already big brother is a mental exercise
but now
you are all going into it having been
quarantined and getting tested like
how does all that affect you you know
this game is a very mental game before
there's a very mental game
it's so going through the quarantine and
you know the testing and everything it's
all preparing you for what you're about
to venture into it's like
okay you're getting these tests yes it's
painful but there is a bigger picture at
hand you want to make sure that your
health is together you want to make sure
you can go in the house and play
and so it puts your mind in the mindset
of thinking ahead you know what it's for
you know why
it's happening get it done just get it
done and let's get it done
right now when was the last time you saw
more than one other human
i haven't seen like more than my
immediate family since march
like i have it and people have been
having get-togethers devon you want to
come here i don't
i have a child i don't i i don't
what will it be like to suddenly be in a
house with
you know x number of new faces it's
gonna be very weird going into the house
because
you know i haven't hugged anybody other
than my immediate family i haven't had
contact with anyone other than my
immediate family so going in and just
being able to be around people with no
masks and being able to hug or
touch and it's been a long time you know
what i'm saying so i don't i don't know
how that's going to be
i i have no idea how that's going to be
got to be honest i've kind of wondered
will there be more hookups than ever
this season because everybody's been
locked up
i'm pretty sure you know that's not
really my thing i don't come there for
the hookup
aspect of it that cbs will never cast
anybody for me to look at anyway
so i do believe that this time around
there will be a lot people have been on
lockdown
hormones are all over the place it might
get a little
watch the live baby job when you're in
there playing
who's on your mind i would imagine uh
your child who are you playing the sport
what would you do with the money if you
won
playing this game there's only one
person on my mind and that's my child
you know everything i do i do for her
so and that's one thing that i have to
keep telling myself because you do get
to a point in the game where it's like
you know what
is this worth it i would rather just be
home with my child instead of dealing
with all the madness in here
but then it's like i'm here for her and
so it's almost like a restart or a
refresh like remember why you're here
so it's definitely for her you know um
getting the money i want to be and it it
might be a little difficult with
everything that's going on with the
pandemic but when all of this does
calm down i want to take my maybe on
trips i want her to know that there's
more than just
where we live you know i didn't expand
and go
out of the country until i became an
adult and so i want her to have those
things and to have those memories and to
you know be able to just say i've seen
parts of the world you know
and then also i don't want her to have
to worry about anything i don't want her
to have to worry about college um
debt or loans and things like that i
want her to be able to just go through
life and understand you do have to work
for what you're gonna get
but it doesn't have to be so stressful
you know i want to
lighten the load for her as much as i
can i'm sure you'll be in there missing
her uh
is there anybody who you are hoping to
see in there or who are you
who you are scared to see in the house i
am excited to see
possibly danielle reyes you know for me
she's the blueprint
like i love her so much and i always
refer to her as my big brother mother
but then it's kind of like bittersweet
because it's like could i play the game
with it all
like when i trust her enough to play the
game with her though same thing about
dan giesling like i love him so much and
i love his gameplay i think he's like
one of the most creative players to ever
play this game
but i would never want to play with him
though it's like i didn't trust him
but then in the same breath it's like
would i be like blindly loyal to these
people
i don't know people that i wouldn't want
to see i would say
anyone that i've ever played this game
with before i wouldn't want to see
anyone that i played this game with
before because
i want a fresh start i want a clean
slate and i don't have time for people
that might be holding on the grudges
from things that happened two three
years ago
like if you ain't let that go and gave
it to god i don't know what to tell you
like
it's a fresh start for me i'm not mad at
you so you know
i just i don't want that extra stress
but this is big brother so i'm pretty
sure there will be
do you think this just has the potential
to be the most intense season ever
i definitely believe this season is
going to be extremely intense this is
all stars like
we come into play you know there's
there's no floating there's no getting
by
like i am i can imagine everyone is
coming in
guns blazing day one